[Music]  hold on Lex I'm picking up something  does that asteroid unusual to you I got  the alert what's up initial reports are  some kind of creature if anyone's  watching us then help this monsters  killing everyone  alert three leaders down and we only  just got here he back up now  creature was not been identified and is  referred to have left memorizing the  just  or near death there's one thing I can't  stand  it's a bully  we meet you Clark  don't hold back or he'll kill everyone  I don't know where you came from but I'm  sending you back  you can't go back after that thing it's  suicide  I have to get back to work this city  beats me  you think it might kill Superman it  would save me a lot of trouble  [Music]